he's the commissioner Rob Manfred who
joins us now commissioner thanks for
joining us how are you I'm good dan how
are you I'm doing okay if I take you
back to mid-march and I give you a
mulligan to do-over knowing what you
know what would you do differently well
I think that the agreement that we
reached in March with the players would
have looked very different I think one
of the difficulties that we encountered
is you know we try to be proactive
trying to get an agreement that
addressed the situation and frankly the
situation evolved differently then than
we expected and made the subsequent
negotiation difficult for us give me a
specific of what you would have put in
or taken out well I I just think we
would have been more explicit about the
need for subsequent negotiation I mean I
think the agreement was clear that it
contemplated playing in stadiums with
fans
we took the we had no obligation to play
unless we could play with fans and the
players understood that we thought it
made clear that there would have to be a
discussion of playing empty I think I
just would have written the words you
know if we're gonna play empty there
needs to be another negotiation I think
that negotiation probably would have
gone a little differently had we done it
but you know that's it's perfect you
know how would you rate the job that you
did like where we are right now that
we're starting spring training again and
we got 60 games look I think the most
important thing to our fans is that
we're gonna make every attempt to get
the game back on the field you know I
know some people have talked about
longer seasons 62 short the reality is
the reality is we weren't going to play
more than 60 games no matter how the
negotiation with the players went or any
other factor 60 games is the outside of
the envelope
given the realities and you know I think
this is the one thing that we come back
to every single day we're trying to
manage something that has proved proven
to be unpredictable and unmanageable I
know it hasn't looked particularly
pretty in spots but but having said that
if we can pull off this 60 game season I
think it was the best we were gonna do
for our fans given the course but even
if the players accepted everything you
offered there was no way that you would
have gone to 80 games it was still going
to be 60 i its the calendar Dan 60 games
in 63 days right now I don't see given
how the reality of the health situation
over the past few weeks how we were
going to get gone any faster that then
then the calendar were on right now no
matter what the state of those
negotiations were and yet you know look
we did get a suboptimal result from the
negotiation in some ways you know we
didn't the fans aren't going to get an
expanded postseason which I think would
have been good with the shortened season
and you know look the players like real
money on the table they left 25 million
dollars with playoff pools 33 million
dollars worth of salary advances but
that's what happens when you have a
negotiation that instead of being
collaborative gets you know into sort of
a conflict situation how many owners
didn't want to resume the season I think
if you gave everybody truth serum there
were one or two that were opposed to the
idea of playing for health reasons the
vast vast majority of our owners wanted
to play and I think from the perspective
of the owners they're making an
investment you know in terms of
additional losses in order to get the
game back on the field because we feel
it's important to have the game back on
the field we owe it to our fans I'm glad
you mentioned the 60 games because a
source
me and I told this audience I don't know
how many days ago is last week or maybe
ten days ago that it was going to be 60
games that was what was agreed to no
matter what the negotiations were going
on the 60 games that was etched in stone
but you know you had to have a hard out
of when you were going to be playing the
the World Series of the playoff games
well is that fair I think that everybody
has certain things that you accept as
really good advice one of the pieces of
advice we received early on from the
medical experts that pandemic experts
that we've been working with is that by
the end of September the risk of another
spike in a shutdown was going up
dramatically given that one of our
guiding principles we were going to
finish no later than September 27th
which was a scheduled date and we were
going to play the postseason on its
normal calendar given that hard ending
what I said about the calendar before in
the 60 games if you look around the
country okay there was no place or no
possibility of us resuming operations
either in home markets or in spring
training facilities and a materially
earlier time than July 1 it just was not
consistent with the public house if you
have to pause the season yes how long
can you pause this season you know I
don't have a firm number of days in mind
I think the way that I think about it
Dan is on in the vein of competitive
integrity right in the 60 game season if
we have a team or two that's you know
really decimated for with the number of
people who had the virus and can't play
for you know any significant
at a time you can have a real impact on
the competition we have to think very
very hard about if somebody tests
positive Brian Cashman the Yankee Jim
said the teams can't announce if they've
tested positive so how do they go on the
injury report
what's the designation their
Commissioner they're just going to be
reported as being on the injured list
like any other you know look the word I
want to be really clear about this this
is not a lack of transparency issue it
is what's allowed by federal law you're
not allowed to be out there talking
about somebody else's medical condition
without their permission you know I
think that the reality in an everyday
game is that people just kind of figure
out what's going on when somebody's not
present no I understand what you're
saying I just didn't know what baseball
what it you know no we're just going to
report them like it is if they're an
injured player like any player he's the
commissioner Major League Baseball Rob
Manfred joining us I'm not sure how to
describe your personality here today I
mean you
exasperated defeated drained I don't I
don't feel any of those things and
really I really don't you know I'm
hopeful is what I am I'm hopeful and I'm
realistic I'm hopeful that we're going
to be able to give the game back to our
fans and I'm realistic about the
challenges that we face going forward
the designated hitter National League is
it here to stay or is this a trial look
I think it's a really important trial is
the way I would say it and I think that
Machir for all the bad things about it I
think it does give us an opportunity it
has given us an opportunity to do
something we've never been able to pull
off before we got a lot of support both
in the American and national league for
the idea that at least in these
circumstances it made really good sense
to use a designated hitter in both
leagues we'll see how our fans react
we'll see how the club is react but you
know it's a really nice opportunity to
maybe get us to a situation where we we
have a single set of rules for both
leagues and then the extra inning
starting in the 10th with a runner on
second base yeah I'm not sure that we're
prepared to abandon extra-inning
baseball permanently I think in the
context of a pandemic when the amount of
time that the players are together is an
important consideration the idea of
playing 18 inning games just didn't make
a lot of sense but again I have always
liked this rule you not talked about it
before I've talked to you about the fact
that we used it during the WBC and it
can be really exciting it can make for a
very exciting end of the game and you
know was kind of wasted on us by the
pandemic in terms of using it in the
major leagues gives us an opportunity to
let our fee and see it and see whether
they like and in practice yeah I
understand with the the short shortened
season and the schedule in the number of
games and days that you don't want to
you know 1415 in a game you know trying
to do back-to-back games I understand
that I'm for the DHR I grew up in a
National League City but I understand
where we are and adding more excitement
here so I could see where you would
probably are how many if I said right
now how many owners would want this and
what the Baseball Players Association
both for this for the D H how do you
think doctor know the Players
Association has historically been in
favor of the universal D H I think most
American League owners are obviously in
favor of the designated hitter rule
that's their game I think what's
happened in recent years you is you had
more and more National League owners who
are open to the idea let me go back to
the Extra Innings thing for just a
second you know and I want to I think
this is important one of the things that
we've done from a health perspective is
trying to minimize the amount of time
our players are together and that was
really the driving issue on X rating
games you know you play an 18-inning
game it makes for a very very long day
in the dugout in a clubhouse in a
relatively confined area so you know
that one was really a pandemic driven
rule more than anything else you have
keeping every but
safe replacing the baseball's there's no
spitting you can't argue with the umpire
I'm guessing can't be if somebody throws
inside inside you can't go to the mound
and I mean these how you gonna police
this look III think that as with any set
of rules the most important thing is
self policing you know I think the
players understand that these protocols
are necessary to keep them safe and keep
the game going we are going to be
constantly and closely monitoring
adherence to the protocols but I will
say I talked to a number of clubs
yesterday's players are reporting and
you know I was really heartened by the
fact that it kind of uniformly what
clubs are saying is players been great
about this they have mass on you don't
have to tell them to where and when
they're off the field they're doing the
right thing and that's good that's good
because there is no you don't have
enough policemen to you know make sure
everybody's doing the right thing you
have to rely on the fact that that we
educate the players explain to them why
we're doing what we're doing and they
self police would you be in favor of
certain in the season as we move forward
no you know not materially I mean I've
always been open to the idea that you
know within the historical bounds which
I see is 154 to 162 you know depending
on what we were doing the playoff
formats in whatever that that I would be
open to that kind of adjustment but not
a a material adjustment look a big part
of our game and one of the biggest
hurdles that we had to get over from a
competitive perspective in terms of
putting a 60 game season out there
there's a huge competitive difference
between a 60 game sprint and 162 game
marathon it's kind of like saying yo
would you be in favor of making the new
marathon 13 months I think the answer is
no no then I can run it you could I
couldn't
what about how does seeding work in the
dugout we're gonna there are going to be
actual markings in the dugout layout the
social distancing and and during that
period of time which may be you know the
whole season where we're not having fans
in the stands we're actually going to
expand outside the physical dugout
itself use some of the front rows of the
same stance what are you doing the rest
of the day what I'm doing the rest of
the day is more zoom calls I had the
club presidents group today I've tried
to you know communicate on a very
consistent basis with the important
groups in the industry that control
people meaning that 30 owners the
general managers the club presidents and
I've had regular calls them today's
Presidents Day and you know a lot this
will be a very busy call because there's
a lot of operational issues that we need
to review and make sure the clubs are on
board on you know I said for the club's
after we announced the season that you
know there's been all this activity in
terms of the negotiation and whatnot in
terms of getting back on the field
but but now we return to the more normal
situation in our game this is about what
the clubs are doing and so communicating
with them in this unique situation
really important I know it's only one
year but I really feel bad for these
minor leaguers and these minor league
cities that you know that they got
crushed here Commissioner they did and
look I want to be as clear about this as
possible we think minor league baseball
is an important part of not just our
business but of the fabric of American
life and the diss it was simply
impossible to do enough testing and to
get protocols in place
in a hundred and sixty minor-league
cities and provide any assurance any
assurance that we could keep those
players safe and while it's
disappointing and I too I feel bad for
the minor-league operators and the
modeling players what happened here with
this season I think is the most concrete
demonstration of the fact that we have
put players safety first in terms of the
decisions we've made thanks for joining
us we appreciate it commissioner good
luck
all right thanks Dan that's Rob Manfred
major league baseball commissioner